hi guys III a today I'm going to watch
my old videos straight up for one hour
the reason I'm doing this is I'm going
to launch my own YouTube channel I hate
watching myself on YouTube but if I
launch my own YouTube channel I have to
watch it all the time so if I watch my
videos 60 minutes straight I feel like
I'm gonna be immune to it so this is my
practice let's do it dark so while ago
we went to Japan for Wasat Japan episode
for the first time I think it was 2017
summer and before we went to Japan we
show this omurice video with kitchy
kitchy for bring me video and also we
okay so Korea again I've never been more
scared in my life
before eating a feeder was eating your
feed
Adam challenged Andrew to make most
difficult Avila and in the video I said
I think he put milk and he didn't and he
chef kitchen kiichi no chef kitchen chef
mata ki ji Facebook messaged me and said
I didn't put milk can you take down the
video and I told him sorry we cannot do
that but we are going to Japan which you
willing to teach Andrew and he said yes
and this video happened and the whole
time when I was in his kitchen whole
time when I was in his restaurant I
could stop laughing cause he was so
funny
I think Adam ADA
this video and he had a hard time
cutting down my giggle behind the scene
I think I just want to watch him a
before I'm sure you actually start
trying to make Omer Isis he had to
practice with this kitchen towel am i
saying right towel okay so we put power
in a flying pan and Chevy motor kit you
can fold power just flipping the pan but
it's very fascinating and then we start
cooking I say this is maybe my most
favorite BuzzFeed video ever see drop
spatula and he said so like so yeah so
he drops patre and he picked it up and
he said [ __ ] and I just lost my at that
point like I yeah he's so funny is it
it's melon I I don't know how to react
this I just like kind of doughy and like
watch this I feel like I watch this more
than hundred times by now and that's why
I didn't I was hoping that there was a
secret then
saying for why I was doing so bad thing
the aging in mice Hong Kong Korea
Causton so why is it a different pan
kidding
mando no capital so all for chef mo
turkey see chef mo tokichi it's fashion
it's like so soul sort of I think he
wears this red ballet hot ballet ballet
because when New Towns 60 in Japan you
wear something red to separate your 16th
birthday and he told us he stopped
wearing something red after he time the
60 okay I see well what are they oh my
god it looks like a water boy yeah
that's it's in a long time it's two
years so brings me back a little bit
memory about whole trip it was Wow
yeah the demi-glace it was really hot it
was August and I remember all of us got
a lot of mosquito bites during this trip
nothing related to this video but just
the behind the scene
so I was translating most of the time
but I feel like chef moto kiichi and
Andres somehow connected insoluble
become instant best friend and I wish
they included in the video they sang a
song together at the end handsome boys
they just fixated on some boys and like
they harmonize its together yeah and one
scoop in there I think maybe this is
Andres first time cooking in a
professional kitchen I think sometimes
it's intimidating like you know gas
stove top it's much much more powerful
than you don't well at the whole so
there's a like a lot of fire and he's
not get used to flippin pound is like so
in a kitchen you have to free your right
hand so you can pick up ingredients you
can use spatula so you usually flip pan
only a left hand if you're right-handed
and I feel like that it's probably most
difficult for Andrew was like I feel
like this it's a part under was
struggling I think he whom the following
the video I'm just talking but I became
to my mind
what else should I talk well I like this
video cuz like I bury on the screen like
I am just background and translating and
making small comments so I think this is
another reason this is my favorite video
I know so I know that like everything I
during I was here it was just so funny
and I was keep laughing and I told Adam
like this shoot was maybe my favorite
and I don't think you can't like I'm I'm
hoping we can capture this excitement at
a dislike for moments in a video and I
think Adam did a great job for editing
and capture everything happening in the
kitchen he and the mother night Scott
for Eagle Toyota okay well okay good
that's it yeah one ladle right should I
let it get hotter and scramble right
look like you got it filled by anything
oh yeah now I'm sure it's and making oh
boy difficult like muting and like I
like he said don't don't don't color in
Chao
it's Japanese onomatopoeia already fill
this omelette but we're just doing this
to practice
I'm not sure I can make this to be
honest with you yeah it's very difficult
I feel like Andrea did a great job
making that just like short amount of
time I think it's only when we weren't
there I think so I think like he did a
great job doing that you know such a
short period period of time okay I would
love to londo who's here my production
managers whisper this is stressful on
screen yeah it was Thanks and then make
the omelette funny and exciting but at
the same time gave me a load of anxiety
we weren't sure if Andrea can make it
happen and you know somehow he has to do
it by end of the video so yeah I was I
got a lot of anxiety watching this video
of the Sangha
scramble scramble scramble scramble
okay okay okay okay it's to me it's gone
too far
right again again
you see do NASA yeah she's not the
Khajiit such a patient teacher and he is
very good at teaching I think he does
coffee that's law but I don't wanna okay
so
coochie-coochie is located in Kyoto and
it's small restaurant and it's very
difficult to get reservation I feel like
we are very lucky to be able to shoot
two three times actually I shop in
coochie-coochie for bring me and eating
your feet and was a ex-ored and I make
him okay so every time I go there it
never gets old it's just it's like
entertainment it's not only restaurant
but I feel like he it's such a great
entertainer so not only eating
um Rice's I also like watching him make
omurice ooh it's kind of watching gosh
oh oh okay
okay let's call it you did it ready : go
Cole ready yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
why else should I cook I know it's not
there yet but I learned a lot of stuff
about making this though even that dude
when you want to erase it
yeah what do you think what how good do
you like I haven't made um right before
I used to make it a lot when I was in
college because it's easy thing to make
not like you know sweet cut Omaha it's
just like make a thing over and put it
on top of the rice and it's quick and
easy dinner so I used to make a lot with
ketchup and I love this video because at
the end who showed us how to he said
what are we say bonus no many people can
make it like this short period of time
so you did great okay well I'm gonna
practice my mouth yeah
yeah he said can we include the bonus
and he showed us how to air grab Allah
and it was crazy so if you hear the
audio like I just like scream and was so
cool and I just so lucky to prepare
thank you to seize her moment
okay this video it's over okay no I
didn't even a bad chicken baby now so
I'm gonna just keep doing keep going
[Music]
okay so next video is tasty cook-off
waitis so the reason we decided to do
this video we just wanted to eat fried
chicken and in order to get in order to
get budget for making a bunch of fried
chicken for everyone it's to make a
video so we just decided to do fried
chicken cooked off so as to me juice
tasty no one is going to be agree so we
decided to do this cook-off all it's
that paste lemon juice Facebook live
yeah
so same game it's 2016 we did a needed
our first Facebook lied for this fried
chicken cook-off and I already made
exact same chicken wing and I won so I
decided to do it again in order to win
but everybody it's fried you know it's
so good I wasn't sure if I count when
you know this time
cause you know everybody its peace it's
different and everybody has different
opinion about
chicking and also I think somebody told
me chicken wings is not fried chicken so
I wasn't sure I did it anyway because I
had an illicit B we're gonna make spice
mix we start with the most important
ingredient roundup Sichuan peppercorns
it brings a spiciness but it's not the
same heat as like a traditional chili
kind of mix your math Tang a little bit
cumin chili flakes yeah true so yeah so
I was a little bit worried that you know
everyone has a different taste and like
maybe my chicken wing dates now
somebody's you know maybe some people
doesn't like that flavor combination but
a lot of people like that so now I
occasionally cook fried chicken for
somebody's birthday but some people
doesn't like desserts somebody does I
make this chicken wing instead of
beginning of my education and food
basically was just working with a bunch
of and also I didn't I'm making like
yeah I was asked to be on a little
cuckoo video but I know and I still yeah
cringe
what's my spells you know also I have a
such a bad haircut I'm so like trying to
hide my butt hair girls mirin sake sugar
it's very simple and I'm grating go
and give more flavor um Seema becoming
syrupy texture now I'm hanging a wings
which you don't need to the man too long
because it's it will get soggy very nice
and shiny just uh for final patch I
sprinkle with toasted sesame seeds
that's it
good it's not only paste but also like
atmosphere so like whenever you eat
outside or like when you're eating with
it makes food taste better
I've been told the losers have to do the
dishes all of us are eating each other's
fried chicken so I think we all weren't
at the end both of you guys chicken is
really good it's very different so it's
kind of difficult to compare I think
it's like three of us making totally
different thing
[Music]
I think the producer wanted me to be in
there because he wanted to showcase
different fried chicken rather than just
like you know just fried chicken so I
made japanese-style fried chicken and
Mike made Xuan paper fried chicken
what's very good but yeah I think at
this time I still feel very
uncomfortable in a camera so I was
telling myself this is my last time to
be on on the camera yeah this is kind of
like good practice of like fried chicken
should be my opinion crunchy simple
batter but you know like I don't know
how to describe yeah I feel like if I'm
watching myself 60 minutes straight so
do we want like I feel like I feel not
too uncomfortable anymore
also I have a huge head so the good
fairy hearts Allah
it's like my temple
[Music]
so look at old logo I mean not sure how
many people recognize our old the logo
we kind of push it up so now we are
watching unsolved Apple Pater video so
this video happened because one of their
showrunner Katie she slugged us there
was a bull saying spaghetti and Apple
Pater
and she was wondering if we can make it
and I said for sure I thought it was
very inspiring that goals mentioned food
names I feel like I can befriend with
that ghost like Hungry Ghost this was my
first time shooting with an assault team
and this shoe kind of happened very
quickly and I have no idea what's kind
of skill at all there had about I feel
like they did a great job Potato Head
Start so it can be easily so tater tots
it's something I never had until I moved
to us and I came up with this recipe
cuz I wanted to make kind of similar
shape but if I have an opportunity to
make a potaters I might want to use
potato as well because also some people
said it's no potato good stater thought
Peter means like Oh Peter right so it
should be it's basically a poacher oh
it's delicious though I like it without
sugar Anacin
don't throw it in the lemon tree the
next grading Apple gonna be careful
careful we don't wanna lose her great
yeah I feel like how many times have you
cut yourself if I was asked to be in an
unsolved video I would definitely say no
because I'm scared of ghosts and I feel
like if I I feel like I cannot take
shower with my eyes closed
Kathy you know normal thing
it scares me so much I just saw the
picture of mama and every night I think
about it and I Hey and I want to erase
my memory about mama it's very scary so
yeah I don't know how Ryan the shame
dude like staying overnight in a haunted
house no I never seen a ghost
so I maybe that's another thing I am
afraid of because I've never seen that
and I might imagine a Shawn what's that
oh yeah yeah I grown up I grown up in
Japan there is bunch of scary ghost
stories and like there's dolls there
there is a doll like the hair is keep
growing or this kind of scary picture
like you know goals picture it's always
scared of me
all right yeah but if you don't want the
water in the apples because if it's a
friendly and a Hungry Ghost who likes
eating food you know suggesting
spaghetti and up alerts I feel like it's
less scary one at a time Ryan it's so
much brighter here it goes okay my head
hurts what's kind of torture of this
yeah it's a good time to like yeah
subscribe my channel that's right here
thank you
stick them down here maybe you really
know it's good there we go
other things you need me to cook around
here why did you say that in such a
threatening tone it was more like yeah
okay I'm not too uncomfortable watching
this video because I always wanted to be
a background person and I think this
video as well like I'm kind of on a
background kind of sidekick instead of
main character so this video it's okay I
wish I could have done it with one hand
but and I think Ryan mache had such a
great chemistry like they're best
friends like I take I don't know well
but as long as like I was with them I
felt like they have like good you know
friendship going on so
[Music]
yeah so if you're making Hitoshi which
is creampuff or zero I show the tip when
you bring up the dough if he is dropping
like triangular shape it's the good
amount of egg in there so that it's a
good tip this is the dangerous step
right this is what we're going to likely
burn ourselves yeah you know I keep my
oh you're gonna just to be very
transparent when we were using this like
star shape dip the Apple graded or Apple
stock so we actually change the tape and
was a little bit scared could stay it
ways they're frying in a hot oil and
they'd never done that before and the
first time when they drop the door it
was a little bit squashed there's our
first just letting you know like I'm
watching this completely muted right now
who's like if I'm listening audio I feel
like I'm kind of distracted
well Nuggets gold nuggets like we're
digging through a little litter box well
I'm excited see you on the other side
yeah cheers ghouls to ghouls
it's okay
there's the best damn apple tater I've
ever had creamy delicious crispy I like
thing it's too I'm sold
it complements the outside crispy
exterior I love it you know what put it
on our tombstones the cool boys love
Apple taters I can see myself laying on
a beach just sort of like staring at
people
can I have no one they're not gonna have
Apple taters I'm having me apple thing
you keep talking you know I'm gonna keep
can I have a break my head hurts
all right next
I try to make a pie wait some service oh
my god taking a dish without any trash I
don't know why it's the dish yeah hey
it's gonna be a surprise and I don't
like surprise you know you know daily
life when you're cooking so I mentioned
before I like to be a sidekick in the
main character and this video it's
probably my first videos just being by
myself and it's painting lunch plates
I love the crew it was all girls and he
was leader producer Sadie was a
co-producer and Debbie she did audio so
like for girls matter this video
happened and the Women's History Month
right now in a March
so it's a great video
is the brown sugar what we gonna do I
think I'm gonna use more granular yeah
so we went to this grocery store they
sell grocery groceries in bulk I've
never been there before but I think it's
a you know great idea bringing your own
container it's you know reduce your own
waste I kind of changed my mind last
minute I was gonna just make traditional
apple pie but I remembered making this
roads shape apple pie and after I went
to grocery store I changed my mind
so I wish I chose red apple instead of
green apple and I have very little
knowledge about recycling and or like
reducing waste so this challenge I
trying to make this video I tryna use
everything I purchased like I wanna I
wanted to use apple skin and you know
like Apple like I sort of hope for
what's waist but actually it was food
waste it's not the waist so you know I
learned a lot of things to making this
video to make things and now I'm adding
the ice water in a idols
yeah
so since I don't like watching myself
cooking talking waste
I'm thinking maybe make a recipe video
for my youtube channel I'm thinking
maybe making recipe video just me
cooking but kind of focusing on my hand
so I don't need to be on camera how much
and also some people said the sticker on
the Apple that eats biowaste but um I'm
also not sure I should be thinking that
is it true yeah I told me that's do you
know okay
that's right so what I feel feet doesn't
work I'm going to macerate with sugar
1/2 cup of sugar
I don't know yeah sure okay senator 30
minutes so it's gonna get soft yeah also
a lot of people made this pie and tag me
on instagram thank you so much
I love when you guys do it love our on
the saw face
[Music]
yes like here and here and here also
this video was for gufo which is a
healthier more ha vehicle like whites
good fold slogan yeah so go for it's
like healthy lifestyle videos and they
have you know to be honest they're broke
some more beautiful than pasties like
they have better looking balls better
looking played so wide I'm cooking like
I yeah I like I don't know what to say
okay so I have a leftover dough what's
kind of pattern shoot me yeah I'm
getting disoriented
since I'm watching myself for 30 minutes
now I think oh boy
30 more minutes you know I said 90
minutes in a video honestly when don't
let me study
no what about if I make pie oh yeah I
made my name because I had leftover
dough
my name is very close to the pie
just like one lying so I'm gonna go bake
it should have made weird huh
I mean I did this video I love how she
played with graphic and like very cute
emojis I love making videos I already
feel good about it
both my pies and amount of trash I
created yeah also I read origami with
butter oil daily life if you are more
conscious about what to choose how about
that with my coworkers and let's see
what they think wow those look like
sausages it looks in my pie any waste
this is the amount of trash I yeah I
told them I might wonder my waist
without the cords and if they said they
eat apple corer also doesn't it taste
better knowing that hardly any trash was
created I'm actually really impressed
because I have not tried to make
something to SEM Bish's but you've
inspired me this is so good simple tasty
delicious tasty no wasting look sad I'm
sorry
by the way that's a good fool logo at
the end my hundreds in there the one
holding a shovel it's it's my hand
so I did this video for what's the
BuzzFeed blew the game channel okay so I
did with this video for multiplayer it
was my first time doing video with them
and I like cooking in real life I don't
play video game at all I feel like the
last time I play to something was Mario
Kart and if it's just like there its
bunch of buttons confuses me on the
controller so I don't play game and I
think Chelsea invited me to do bats feet
alive and we play it Cooking Mama
together and it's just like super
difficult if you're cooking something
you're cooking with you things about
controlling with controller it's way
more difficult and this video this game
is I was I struggled very hard and I had
to open a refrigerator take a steak from
the refrigerator and when I put on top
of the counter
suddenly the steak disappeared and I was
looking for steak it's not on the floor
it's not on corner of the counter when I
open the drawer
the stick was in her head and it's just
like I don't know about yeah it's it's
just way too difficult like look like
knives
it's knives are everywhere and I just
I'm dreaming about a way playing game I
had a fun cuz it's BR so you were in a
world and you kind of get used to in a
virtual reality with a virtual reality
right okay why do you say like fake okay
so you wear this VR goggles on like okay
so you wear this be our thing and you
feel like you're in a different world
but when you take off that the BR thing
you are in a small room with you know a
bunch of people around you so yeah it
was fun but it was just difficult to
play yes my ear hurts okay my head hurts
so I have to have a headset break oh
yeah that's why I bought yeah something
like depends on the headset my head
start hurting so I that's why I bought
air pots
it's sponsored by Apple oh yeah I this
point I gave up using utensils I start
grabbing everything by my hand Clubhouse
take and put on the top of the plate I
[Music]
had to restart multiple times because I
just couldn't do it and
I put whole butter in a pan yeah I think
it's a good thing because this is
quarter size I'm gonna do it again if I
have opportunity but not sure if it's
because of me or this game because it
was very great maybe I'm good our game
depends on the game I'm good at what's
the name Mario Kart just Mario like yeah
I didn't yeah
yes he said when I was little like I'm
not into video game that much so I
didn't grown up playing any of them
where's Nick yeah I dropped a steak on
the floor pick it up to the customer I'm
not a talkative person so it's I'm
having a difficult time talking about my
thoughts I don't know why I feast ah so
somehow if we start slapping this waiter
he's great at playing games though
[Music]
a salty peppery
since I'm having a very difficult time
to react my own beliefs for 60 minutes
I'm not going to react video for my own
YouTube because it's difficult I don't
know it's it's yeah maybe I'm gonna have
Alex to my video okay okay yeah how many
times do we have first team panel
it's like making team found it's much
much easier than reacting my own video
oh yeah I had to make wedding cake so I
don't make mistake
chef's life I'm so bad at this okay
let's do one thing so why do I was
making wedding cake I basically
destroyed a whole kitchen and somehow
the drawer wall was on the countertop
everything was on the floor and I just
couldn't wait make it happen so I had to
give up so I gave up making wedding cake
you know what we should do we're gonna
rerecord I'm going to react to my thirty
minutes video okay it doesn't stay on
the countertop is it because I have so
much things I also think about cooking
videos oh you cannot eat it if you make
it I think that's the things I don't
like about playing video game like I
don't like about playing video games
because I can not eat it even though I
spend a lot of times making it yeah
I like making real food instead of watch
out food Oh oui chef what you went here
check this out I figured it out I don't
know what to tell you keep it mixing
keep mixing oh God let me creep out my
wallet pour it into a pan it's so good
yeah that's my favorite part I know that
but can you explain why does people
wanna watch people playing video game
what do you think why do you think yeah
like why do you want to watch this I
wonder this is not my idea you know this
is Spencer's idea yeah sounds good it's
not you know like if I think about it I
watch people cook it's like food in
their work so maybe that's the fun part
they learn how to be good at playing
video game maybe that's why I watch Jack
okay so I can oppose right chance on
call oh yeah I'm nine and today I'm
gonna have two chefs compete to make my
dream dish wha-ha-ha so this video was
my first I draw you cook and Eli he has
such a wild imagination but also I don't
know like how much I can reveal about we
asked him what superhero eat for
breakfast and Eli goats like cereal so
like he was kept drawing cereal box so
we had to ask him in a different way
what superhero eats to be a superhero
and he came up with this crazy
[Music]
so to be honest with you I love kid but
I'm not great with kids because I don't
know what to talk to them alex is very
good with kids could she went to she did
oh yeah with cheese like she went to
Sweden and I think she kind of like
doing a nanny for family so she knows
what kids like what kids like to eat and
she's great with kids and so but this
was very fun because like there is no
but making this videos so much fun cuz
we could do anything we wanted to make
we don't have any time element to be
they don't have any Linux for quadrat
and I what I came up with I thought it
was cool kids they don't like it and I'm
not sure if you guys watch second
episode I also lost so I'm about to time
you later
oh I Cho you cook for gob slob I'm going
to make mint chocolate oh yeah it's
melted hard candy on top he took a lot
of time drawing this radioactive symbol
so I want to incorporate this element to
my dish
so flop I wondered if when we shot this
video it was ha ha I think it was August
and I wanted to make cookie and a cookie
dough what's like melting and
we had a tooth on those that you know
air conditioner because of like it makes
noise so it was very very that's what I
remember
I'm going to arrange some eggs egg has
to be room I also like I don't know who
did this words but it was cooking
experience to Alex but I have no
experience with kids I actually spent a
year as an au pair so I feel like I know
what a little boy yeah so I think we
gonna shoot another season hope I draw
you good and I hopefully I will be in it
but you know I lost why so we see they
don't want to catch me I just have to
practice with you know being surrounded
by little people so I start
understanding what they like because I
didn't want to use food coloring because
you know like I don't want to artificial
ingredients but what I learned kids love
the facial color
kids love bright colors and strong
flavor combination I learned a lot have
to start think about what I'm going to
make I'm going to save half for my
chakra cooking right I'm going to rest
my dough in a refrigerator I'm gonna
melt Kartik an beads and I have to pick
the color
Hey look who's here can I make what
should I do
so I'm watching my jeweler could be
careful I'm so
box yeah you are so quick I was growing
bum bum and wow I don't remember much it
was all a blur I mean a while
I remember messing up that batter though
oh yeah but you you are still ahead of
me by yeah but didn't you catch up at
the end I think you still ended up like
finishing much much earlier than me the
expert here yeah you know about cakes a
lot no you're the desserts no I'm the
kids no it's no baby I'm the kids yeah
these strawberries strain this just so I
mean like I literally don't even
remember what I did I'm like this is all
new to me
I'll be watching 60 minutes straight 60
60 of 1 now the videos of you yeah Wow
how do you feel I feel like so weird to
watch me right I don't like yeah me too
I pick out everything it's like I
already do a lot of things wrong and
right but all my mistakes are recorded
for the world to see speaking of mistake
and like floats look at my oh yeah I'm
doing a white chocolate stuff we've done
like a regular sized chocolate chips so
it's nicer to fold them into like a
frosting yes that is some radioactive
goo this same video no no no oh video
we do we fifty-five minutes of footage
Wow yeah just like four or five videos
what's your favorite beeping you feed
the omellete horizon yeah what about
your favorite video what's your favorite
video of mine mm-hmm behind the face
probably raindrop cake yeah
oh this was the bad part did you put
water look like seeds once I added the
food coloring it started to see that
it's gonna get really dry crumbly and we
know hey I like don't even want to talk
about it because everyone everyone
ripped me apart but I would just like to
say I got advice from someone else other
than real liar I'm not even gonna think
I'm lying in don't even include this Oh
God
wait really wait you're not editing it
you should edit cuz it's part I'm just
not tell me this okay well bleeps out a
whole thing okay
let me just set the record straight yeah
they added this to make me look like a
liar and I didn't appreciate it but I
would just like to say this was a
friendly competition we are best friends
no no bad feelings but geez I just got
ripped apart in these comments because I
know y'all love RIA I love you too but
sad it hurts my soul feel the clothes
not the knife and I enjoy knowing
towards me they're nice to you no no
it's no toy to you like for the kids too
oh the kid yeah yeah I mean the kids got
a god
be nice be nice it's a friendly
competition and the great thing about
tasty is that we're always helping each
other so that's the part of the job
mm-hmm you know and we didn't win
anything we won money although everybody
knows that Ria's about are bigger than I
am that's obvious
but it's the kid that was just figuring
out what the kid wants that's a tricky
one this is a really fun competition we
had a lot of fun yeah yeah I heard and I
thought I made a great thing and look
guys you did but he said like oh yeah
I I mean I don't know why I guess Jolly
Ranchers yeah and he didn't love it
tastes like a mint milkshake I look I
kind of like one thing he didn't like it
he did the other straw it was confused I
think I don't know why tastes a lot like
a strawberry smoothie not really sure
what this is didn't even try it though
he doesn't know also wasn't super
impressed my alien cookie and which made
me well my icing looked like really
weird and I think that's he liked it
because he liked that because it's
exactly look like what he draw I tried
yeah but like see he still says feels
weird to mine yeah he did what he did to
you weird weird weird yeah it's not
difficult than I think it tastes weird
he says it tastes strange it's chocolate
[Laughter]
the I see is literally just like
buttercream no doesn't but you know like
it's very unpredictable coudn't kid
you made a little elf and and if they
didn't I know yeah and the time I did it
with Alexis I I made a literal thing and
they didn't like yeah fine so how can we
win oh can I win I'm gonna start paying
off candy yeah yeah it's it's a very
difficult competition it's not yeah and
I just have to say I am just naturally
competitive first thing so I like to win
yeah but can you blame me don't you like
to win I don't like competition oh I
don't know it's just in my blood
yeah good for you what's your what's
your sign a Taurus it's a competitive
well I'm actually a Taurus Aries is cusp
so I say I'm the best of bull in Scorpio
by the way mysterious so I'm on the
Apple books I'm on the chair on the
Apple box these are the risky yeah well
good times yeah gonna watch the next one
it's that these things that last one oh
you already watch the other one yeah oh
yeah you wanna know in it glad to be a
part of it see you next
yeah thank you for singing bye oh my god
it was the longest one hour in my life
oh yeah I today it's my lunch day for my
youtube channel
again please watch and subscribe I have
no date for my second video but I will
try my best thank you for subscribing
for those who already subscribe
I know I said I'm going to upload my
video three months ago so thank you for
your patience and thank you so much for
your support
you guys are the best see you next time
[Music]
what am I gonna do I just have to do the
head massage my painful heart I have
huge head and
[Music]